walk him to this video playing nobody's
pawn nobody's pawn in a 15 minute you
see for poops with no can go I can play
fire for a change didn't do that too
often I played many games with b6 the
English Defence english defence against
the English okay well probably Knight f3
or g3 here John I'm not quite sure if he
goes g3 what what am I going to play
against it
okay something else hmm yeah well after
that of course i can go d 50 black has
three main options d5 bishop before or
g6 hmm Bishop before going four clock
weekend flew into developments very
often a good idea oops sorry okiie form
aha well that's an interesting that's an
interesting move order actually yeah
normally it comes from a form we should
be four and then d3 but okay that's
that's a very playable very playable
line often associated with the names of
which who has played it and well I have
played it as well with white normally
was g3 of course not with Bishop you too
but it's not not a bad line at all okay
um the thing is black now does not
already want to take on c3 you can do
that but it's not leading to much what
I'm trying to do is I try to play Bishop
c5 and keep the bishop and I'm securing
a square him okay interesting hmm
okay Bishop c5 there is Bishop g5 and
that's not good
I cannot really allow him to take on
before that's not good it's not so much
the bishop but he also will get d
foreign and everything hmm
my way six was really bad I mean we need
to play Bishop c5 first bah yeah I can
take on d5 CD 97 but he's just going to
go with D for and have the better
position quite clearly da Bao a6 was
really terrible okay now my bishop is
stranded at least that can go to c5
without losing any material
okay let's think about this where's this
piece going maybe oh all the way here to
be 60 this night to g6 maybe or is there
some entirely different way to play what
about c5 maybe c5 maybe takes Knight
takes to get the night back into play
and if it's not if he's not taking okay
I had a brief gained quite some useful
space of course this position is
slightly better at least at least
slightly better for wine maybe more
simply worth ID for my intention was D
for Bishop g4 but not not clear well now
I can go to see five probably okay they
can go deform yeah after my my bad move
a six I'm struggling here and now he
should just play the form with a
slightly better position at least what I
just noticed though I can maybe drop it
back to be 6m yeah I don't need to take
or anything
and then maybe Bishop g4 neon he cannot
so easily play d5 a special b3 would
really harm has structure quite
substantially maybe age 3 was an idea to
prevent this maybe on d5 does also
Bishop takes a three now maybe you can
take on 26 then
so Bishop f3 or not takes on a three
takes on 66 on e to Queenie Julia that's
not too great
okay only seven I wasn't so sure where
the night is going here at least know
that 9075 might be might be a route I
could have played Bishop e3 maybe this
was was possible but I'm not sure if
this double porn is some such a big
achievement probably just f6 them it
weakens the light squares but where else
Queen d7 lots of this is loose left stop
looking good what's so queen bee three
so let's just do this of course it might
cause me problems on the light square
sets sets really care
ok so a five here maybe
fighting for the c5 square really aha
Jim no no big choice really now maybe g6
yeah this is not neither five result not
very nice to face okay maybe you can go
Quincy for an attending Queenie section
yeah
now neither 5m it's not that is not very
comfortable really not hmm still 95
Wow King edge a time the salts are just
night XG six probably and not okay night
g6 takes Queen takes Queen yet and I
wanna know I cannot play that it's not
not really playable at all then the
voice queen anne i def five year Wow can
I knew that f6 is weakening the light
squares but I am I really didn't think
it would i would to haunt me so quickly
I don't even see a move really that is
acceptable
yeah okay I need to play something but
it's not not good at all attending after
night f5 to play an idea fate is so
terrible really maybe I can make a text
before work somehow night f5a be 496 be
takes a three it's probably a completely
moronic exchange sacrifice I simply
forgot that this is a means wow poor
what game help help ah Jesus
hmm well I didn't drink anything before
this game but it sure makes the
impression that I did Wow
yeah that's completely lost takes Queen
takes King edge 8 there is Luke c3r ok 3
checkmate is absolutely nothing against
that fantastic just fantastic so that's
a plea over
okay it's just as lost as all the other
moves but maybe I can somehow confuse
him nitey such a double check here and
then I go here yeah of course is winning
but I just hope that I'm not mated
immediately and maybe I can get some
sort of Swing lon the GF are going game
what a disaster really yeah maybe I
should have avoided f6 altogether it
looked like total total crap to be
honest but what the heck really
remarkable okay should I what should I
do now
yeah well you don't want to trade Queens
ready being material down with Knight f6
s Bishop g5 and it's not improving in
any way quite quite the opposite and
what else I mean I can go to f8 yeah
it's not helping maybe I would get the
e4 pawn somehow maybe at the moment it's
it's pinned down it's a pin so f 3 is
not possible rookie one look chief or
maybe
rookie one rookie form no he's doing
something else entirely I can take here
take on you forever I want takes on b6
takes on d2 not sure that is helping
okay but at least after Bishop takes a
look takes this e for hanging at a three
hanging maybe I get one back okay we've
got one pawn back and it would be really
nice if somehow I get the knight Knight
to f4 to to get some counter play it's
still just a pawn cannot cover g6
raining
now he can take it as simple as that you
can take the pawn Knight f4 night f7
even just scrubbing everything
okay he made a useful defensive moves
there any way to Twitter at least pose
some sort of problem night to d4 maybe
night it's also total total nonsense 92
we can just play King f2 of course
wow what a catastrophe of a game room
Wow check
the worst is i mean ii didn't even need
to find anything great for that I just I
just basically called myself him check
you
yeah 95 I mean there's just died aged
form Jeff but one else really yeah I bet
everything winds now but 97 King e7 Roxy
17 d 6 can only hope for some sort of
miracle maybe taking g5 is the easiest
really
but okay there will probably be many
ways to check
yeah that's it black resins can just a
completed yet them if I completely
forgot about 96 I mean how out stupid
can you be I thought how long almost
three minutes and that simply forgot
that you can take on g6 it's not that I
didn't see it I mean I saw that this is
check this is terrible and yachting and
then you play rookie yet to really make
it completely dead layer sometimes you
just brain that right ah I mean this
position is not not any good anyway but
the whole thing is that the computer
actually wants to play this the digest
and why isn't true who could see three
winning now ah what a defense
know-it-all it's all about this line
rooks III and the Queen here and this is
actually winning for black Wow okay the
problem is that that this is probably
the only player been working a jade I
really didn't see I didn't see anything
good and then at the end I went ok let's
do look yet and i forgot about night
because night f5 was also a problem i
mean this this is also very good for
wild and of course only the second best
compared to this move check yeah this
was very precise maybe i should have
played Bishop g4 here those may be
making it too easy fine
check check check check yeah this is
what sauce the most precise way to do it
really yeah just not good yeah I must I
must play differently here it's just 97
it's not it's not good then I can I mean
f6 you can already it's already
debatable but AG this position cannot be
so bad I mean maybe let's say slightly
worse but it shouldn't be a complete
disaster maybe I really already played
this plate this wrong and should have
taken here only three this was probably
the the much easier way to do it yeah I
just thought I must play this just just
avoid avoid it altogether yeah my
problem was that Bishop g5 I really I
really didn't appreciate and so this is
a big big improvement when other moves
I played a very strong game here but so
just like that and that is not as
picture here knowledge for here was also
also possible young Jim yeah these are
the kinds of game that prevent me from
going over 2,300 in this rating you once
in a while someone really plays a great
game I mean and I won't you play this
was just a just terribly played by me
well a six it's just blah and just
completely completely idiotic of course
he played this really strong i mean like
95 all those are spot on must must do
that and um champ here actually ad for
of course stronger
Jeff I don't know okay i guess i should
play another game thanks for watching